- Hello, I'm Alvin.
And some of you guys
might have been wondering
of the new status on the
Making It Big season might be.
And I'm excited to announce
that it is going to have a brand new host.
Someone who is very
charismatic, passionate
and genuine about giant food
and is gonna be bringing
a lot of exciting new energy to the show.
- What's up guys?
My name is Tway and I'm the new host
of this season of Making It Big.
You might have seen me online
sharing my easy to follow recipes
and I also host a lot of
delicious popups in real life.
Now, I'm ready for the biggest
and most exciting food adventure yet.
This season, my friends have challenged me
to make their favorite
food big and I mean big.
Tune in and watch the new
season of Making It Big
because it's gonna be epic.
- Thank you for supporting the show.
Genuinely, it means a lot that
you guys have stuck with us,
commented, liked, shared
or simply just watched
the crazy shenanigans that we get up to.
But I hope to look forward to many more.
Peace.